[Music]  you know I'm surprised you still here I  want to put you gone home now  hammer classes I bet you didn't know how  quickly this town gets masala comes  attention customers the local police  have issued an 11 o'clock curfew so be  sure to get home quickly and safely  what's the true fee for a manhunt call  the sheriff why the guy that they're  looking for I think she would care who  they won't last night in my room  never get there like balloons just like  that with my daughter  big time written on that balloon did you  get a good look at him my friend fully  dressed like a like a clown  [Music]  Donna  you can monitor possess but it was never  activated the paranormal ship clock or  physically it's tricky so be sure the  music body heat  [Music]  [Music]